première question ont montré aux
modalités de production d'hydrogène
notre pays entend industrialiser la
production d'hydrogène bas carbone par
lectra lise de l'eau l'avait évoqué ce
choix implique une alimentation des
électrolyseurs par de l'électricité
renouvelable ou l'électricité d'origine
nucléaire qui est grandement décarbonés
vous l'avez évoqué également alors
l'union européenne semble privilégiée à
ce stade un hydrogène vers excluant sa
réflexion le recours au nucléaire
l'aca motif d'inquiétude pour la france
dans quelle mesure la stratégie
européenne aura-t-elle une influence sur
la stratégie française même si on a
enfilé en filigrane la question de
l'abandon du nucléaire en france
le plan présenté par le gouvernement ne
mentionne pas en revanche la piste d'un
d'hydrogène bleus produits à base
d'énergies fossiles notamment de méthane
associé à une méthode de capture et de
séquestration du co2 pourquoi ce choix
les méthodes de capture et de
séquestration du co2 ne semble pas
suffisamment sûre ou matures
j'aimerais également vous interroger sur
les modes d'approvisionnement des
électrolyseurs en électricité rte dans
un récent rapport que vous avez évoqué
également identifie trois modes
d'alimentation un approvisionnement des
électrolyseurs sur marché sur les
périodes de surplus de production
d'électricité renouvelable au nucléaire
un approvisionnement des électrolyseurs
sur le marché l'électricité en base hors
situations de tension et enfin un
approvisionnement des électrolyseurs
avec de la production nous là dans le
cadre de modèles locaux ces modèles
conduit c'est à des enjeux techniques et
connaît très différents quel pourrait
être le modèle privilégié par la
stratégie française et pour quelles
raisons enfin j'aurais quelques
questions sur la compétitivité de
l'hydrogène décarbonée rte estime et qui
quel que soit le mode de retenue le prix
de l'hydrogène décarbonée de noray
structurellement supérieur à celui de
l'hydrogène gris c'est à dire une
réponse que nous fait le secrétaire
d'état ici sur une question que nous
aurions pu poser sur des projets locaux
même en tenant compte de baisse de coûts
importantes des extras liseur c'est
pourquoi le gouvernement a prévu la mise
en place d'un mécanisme de soutien
public sur un modèle proche de ce qui
existe aujourd'hui pour les énergies
renouvelables ne faudra-t-il pas
complétée à terme ce mécanisme de
soutien par une taxation importante du
co2
cette contrainte est elle d'ores et déjà
intégrée par la stratégie
gouvernementale
voilà un ensemble de questions pour
chacun des intervenants je pense que
chacun aura compris sur quelles
questions il devra se positionner
merci sur un délit la parole à monsieur
houlgate
merci président merci donc aux
intervenants pour cette table ronde
monsieur laurent michel vous avez dit
que à l'heure actuelle donc la france
consomme à peu près un million de tonnes
d'hydrogène en grande partie bien
évidemment de l'hydrogène carbonées ce
qui engendre 9 millions de tonnes de co2
par an il faut savoir d'ailleurs que que
ce gaz est exclusivement utilisé pour le
raffinage des produits pétroliers la
production d'ammoniac la production
d'ammoniac pour les engrais azotés ou
encore celle du méthanol qui est destiné
aussi à la production de plastique alors
vous êtes peut-être me confirmer ou pas
néanmoins moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est
de savoir c'est que dans l'hypothèse et
c'était un des grands objectifs de la
décarbonisation de cet hydrogène pour
avoir de l'hydrogène vers quelle serait
la quantité d'énergie nécessaire
moi j'en étais resté à 50 5 kilowatts
par part
de d'énergie pardon électrique par par
kg d'hydrogène produit donc est ce que
vous allez pouvoir nous donner un peu d
idées d ordre de grandeur que j'ai pas
tout à fait compris tout à l'heure
l'estimation que vous avez fait et
toujours sur ce même thème
on sait très bien et une note de l'ademe
qui datent d'un an dit que
malheureusement la technique de
l'électro lise fait que les rendements à
l'heure actuelle sont très faibles dans
le power to power à savoir des
rendements qui sont selon la note de la
dette de l'ademe de 2 23%
donc est ce que il y a des marges de
manoeuvre pour augmenter ses rendements
et à ce titre donc en quoi le plan de
relance pourrait d'une certaine façon
être orientés vers la recherche pour
augmenter la performance de ces
électrolyseur et puis aussi peut-être
aussi la réduction de l'impact
environnemental de ces électronique b2c
électrolyseur pardon qui en outre un
haut niveau de leur construction
et puis enfin dernière question l'europe
a une ambition c'est de faire rouler je
crois c'est cent mille camions à
l'hydrogène est ce qu'on a je dirais une
idée de la consommation énergétique qui
serait nécessaire pour produire
justement cet hydrogène qui servirait
donc de carburant pour ses camions merci
merci je vous propose de répondre à ces
deux interrogations de mes collègues
merci qui répond en premier mais c'est
évoquer ces questions importantes et qui
sont effectivement au coeur de nos
réflexions concernant le
l'électricité nucléaire donc je les lis
dans mon propos introductif on dispose
en france d'un atout majeur qui est de
l'électricité décarbonés et donc il
importe que dans les approches et dans
les textes qui sont adoptées je sois en
france mais surtout au niveau européen
le l'électricité décarbonés d'origine
nucléaire soient prises en compte alors
il ya effectivement on voit bruxelles
s'opposer j'irai 2 deux clans d'une part
un certain nombre de pays tels que le
portugal l'espagne le danemark
l'autriche
il y en a et le luxembourg voilà qui
sont plus ou moins richement doté en
énergie renouvelable et qui prône à
l'utilisation d'un de l'électricité
renouvelable seul et puis d'autres pays
dont la france mais également les pays
bas mais également les pays de l'est
l'europe la tchéquie la slovaquie la
roumanie la bulgarie la pologne qui sont
en faveur donc d'un mix plus variés
notamment l'adoption de valeur
ne pas ne pas exclure l'électricité
nucléaire donc des points ont été
marqués récemment et alors que les
textes il ya quelques mois étaient
encore très pro renouvelables seul il ya
maintenant une plus grande diversité la
question sur le jeu l'évoqué également
sous la rubrique je dirais neutralité
technologique l'utilisation de
l'hydrogène qu'on appelle bleues c'est à
dire le couplage delà du captage et la
séquestration du carbone ou le captage à
l'utilisation du carbone parce qu'on a
besoin de carbone pour l'économie est
également une formule enfin une forme de
qu'il ne faut pas écarter
et qui peut au moins dans une phase
transitoire être utile pour mettre en
place ces technologies de l'hydrogène
alors je vais aussi quelques ordres de
grandeur sur les énergies possibles
enfin les énergies pendant les ordres de
grandeurs d'énergie nécessaire en fait
ça dépend de du taux de comment dire à
mégawatts 1 mégawatt de d'électrolysé
permet le faire à peu près 20 kg par
heure 20 kg par heure alors ensuite
combien de temps vous pouvez utiliser
votre l'électrolyseur si vous le
l'utiliser uniquement à gueuler
l'énergie éolienne monsieur trenet
dites-leur 2000 heures par an 23 % en
2000 heures par an ça vous fait 40
tonnes par an donc si vous voulez faire
un 40 mille tonnes
c'est un gigawatt donc à un réacteur
nucléaire pour 40 mille tonnes
si au lieu d'alimenter avec de
l'électricité renouvelable onshore
éolienne onshore vous l'utilisez avec de
l'off shore l'éolien offshore là c'est
pas 2000 mais c'est plutôt 4000 heures
donc évidemment c'est
80 tonnes par par mégawatt si c'est le
mix électrique français notamment le
bois utilisé 7500 heure là c'est 150
tonnes par an donc en fait tout dépend
du taux d'utilisation de vaud
électrolyseur sur l'augmentation des
rendements
il ya effectivement et laurent michel
l'a dit il ya encore un effort de
recherche à mener de façon à maintenir
la france un haut niveau d'excellence en
matière de recherche
on est parmi les premiers pays du monde
en dans cette recherche
mais enfin des nos concurrents reste pas
immobile et donc il faut maintenir ce
haut niveau et le programme prioritaire
de recherche
enfin c'est plus tout à fait comme ça
qu'ils s'appellent mai donc il va être
piloté par la nr va viser à augmenter
les l'efficacité dès technologies et par
conséquent augmenter le rendement mais
ce que nous pensons fondamentalement
c'est par le changement d'échelle c'est
par la création de giga factory c'est
par le développement massif que non pour
abaisser les coûts et par conséquent
réduire les aides publiques qui à terme
d'offre de vie devenir nul on n'est pas
en train de se lancer dans une
technologie dans une une wii dans un
développement qui va nécessiter des
soutiens publics a dit à mme éternel le
alors pour le pour les cent mille
camions l'add on parle et dont faty
l'objectif de l'europe à l'horizon 2030
si on compte 160 mille kilomètres par an
11 kg d'hydrogène pour 100 km et ça fait
à peu près 97 térawattheures si vous
comptez qu'un réacteur nucléaire fait
900 mégawatts fait 6 5 térawattheures
par an il vous faut quinze réacteurs
nucléaires lorsque je voudrais dire
aussi sur ce point parce que c'est un
poids qui est souvent ce qui est souvent
évoquée c'est en gros vous allez
l'hydrogène ne fera pas tout la plupart
des modèles au niveau mondial considère
qu'on va vers plus d'électrification
dans des modèles tels que monsieur
treiner le rappeler avec évoqué par ce
rifkin c'est à dire plus décentralisée
plus digitalisées évidemment décarbonés
et on va vers plus d électrification et
la plupart des modèles que quelles que
soient les instituts on va vers une part
de l'électricité dans la consommation
finale d'énergie de l'ordre de 50 à 60 %
mais il faut couvrir le reste faut
couvrir les 40 50 % qui reste sera fait
avec d'autres énergies renouvelables
notamment la biomasse et notamment
l'hydrogène dans la plupart des modèles
qui sont évoqués l'hydrogène ne fait pas
cent pour cent il fait entre 10 et 20%
l'union européenne à l'horizon 2000
cinquante vise 14% 13 à 14%
donc ça remet les choses en place
il s'agit pas d'avoir une vision je
dirais impérialiste de l'hydrogène
l'hydrogène doit être utilisé à bon
escient dans tout ce qui est
décarbonation de l'industrie je sais pas
comment vous proposer de soif plus
utiliser de faire mais comment on fait
de l'acier sens en se passant du carbone
il faut un autre réducteur l'autre
réducteur candidat c'est l'hydrogène en
france pour donner un ordre de grandeur
il ya encore une production de 11
millions de tonnes d'acier en france ça
nécessiterait si on se passe du carbone
du coq
ça nécessite 700 mille tonnes
d'hydrogène par an c'est à dire à peu
près la pole à la consommation actuelle
la consommation actuelle de d'hydrogène
ses huit cent quatre-vingt mille tonnes
dont la moitié seulement est produite
l'autre est produite dans les processus
eux mêmes dans happy dry et dans la
sidérurgie et consommer sur place
donc ça vous donne les ordres de
grandeurs donc c'est un massif mais dans
des soluces dans pour la production
d'engrais pour la production d'acier
pour la cimenterie
il y a il n'y a pas beaucoup d'autres
solutions je dirais même qu'il n'a pas
d'autre que le recours à l'hydrogène
donc là ce que nous préconisons c'est le
l'utilisation de l'hydrogène à bon
escient dans le bain décarbonation
l'industrie lourde et également dans les
transports lourds que ce soit les
camions les trains les bateaux et peut
être à terme les avions merci on va
reprendre une série de questions je vais
donner la parole un autre collègue
monsieur marchand quittant vision où je
crois
frédéric oui monsieur le président je
suis en visio effectivement je vois là
merci pour ce débat beaucoup
l'utilisation d'hydrogène dans
l'industrie dans les transports mais il
ya aussi une utilisation de l'hydrogène
qui sont tout à fait pertinente
aujourd'hui dans le cas de la
décarbonation des réseaux énergétiques
et je voudrais m'appuyer en soit sur la
l'expérience qui a été menée non pas
dans une valise
jane dans un littoral de l'hydrogène qui
aujourd'hui le territoire de dunkerque
avec le fameux retour d'expérience sur
le gris de gestion des réseaux par
l'injection hydrogène pour décarbonés
les énergies qui a permis à son logement
est un centre de soin d'être alimentée
par un nouveau gaz composé d'une part
variable hydrogène et de gaz naturel
c'est un projet qui visiblement est un
succès mais bien évidemment quelques
chants encore investiguer avant de
pouvoir généraliser l'injection
d'hydrogène dans le réseau de gaz
naturel et ça pose une question qui n'a
pas été forcément soulevée mais à mon
sens est aussi essentiel c'est la
question de l'acceptabilité sociale de
l'hydrogène qui est sans doute une des
clés aussi de la réussite du déploiement
et ma question s'adressera plus
particulièrement monsieur michel pour
savoir quels sont les outils
participation citoyenne puisque sur le
territoire de dunkerque qui a eu des
alertes pour permanent avec la
population les outils participation
citoyenne se soient envisagées dans le
plan de relance pour faire en sorte que
cette question d'hydrogène infused tous
les esprits merci merci
on va regrouper question à monsieur de
me remercier remercié les intervenants
pour leurs propos et et adressé un clin
d'oeil à monsieur treiner d'avoir cité
un ancien conseiller municipal damien
jules verne je vais m'empresser de
relire l'île mystérieuse et notamment le
chapitre auquel vous faisiez allusion
j'ai deux questions à vous poser une
première question d'ordre pédagogique et
de compréhension probablement pour
monsieur michel dans le plan de relance
des 100 milliards que le gouvernement a
présenté en septembre dernier il y à 2
milliards qui sont dédiés à l'hydrogène
pour la période 2020 2022 et le
gouvernement a par ailleurs annoncé le
développement pour 2035 d'un avion
neutre en carbone fonctionnant à
l'hydrogène
un projet qui bénéficierait d'ici 2022
de 1,5 milliard d'euros de financements
publics alors l'éclaircissement que je
sollicite
celui ci est ce que ce fameux milliard
et demi
d'euros comprend et est équivalent aux
trois quarts de l'envelope dégagé ou
est-ce que ce milliard et demi vient des
15 milliards qui sont spécifiquement
dédiés au développement et au plan dédié
à l'aéronautique voilà si vous pouviez
me donner une explication à cette
question et parions me donner votre
sentiment par rapport à ce projet
d'avion décarbonés à un moment où comme
vous le savez la filière aéronautique
est catastrophique et j'imagine que le
modèle économique sera particulièrement
intenable si on considère la technicité
les investissements développer et le
volume de ventes d'avions du marché
actuel la deuxième question j'aimerais
vous poser concerne une des propos qu'on
a entendu hier lors de la mission
d'information du transport de
marchandises qui animé par nono
rapporteur madame bonne foi et monsieur
point d'euros il y avait des collègues
qui étaient là tu tabarot monsieur
jacquet et les échanges étaient très
intéressants notamment avec la fntr la
fédération nationale des transports
routiers et sa déléguée générale
florence berthelot qui nous disaient
voilà nous pesons 5000 en entreprise 225
mille salariés année bien sûr l'idéal à
terme serait de développer un camion
électrique ou un camion à hydrogène
mais fin 2022 et sa rejoindre une
question qui a été posée par nos
collègues fin 2022
nous aurons probablement 1000 camions
sur les deux cent mille que comprend la
flotte nationale et un camion hydrogène
ses 650 mille euros l'unité
c'est à dire cinq à six fois plus cher
qu'un camion classique diesel et donc
vous comprenez bien et nous disait tels
que ce n'est pas pour demain que nous
allons développer une grosse flotte de
camions à l'hydrogène en tout cas à mon
avis on sera loin des 100 mille camions
qui était évoqué tout à l'heure dans les
objectifs européens
à noter également que on en était au
stade prototype et que donc le modèle
économique étaient particulièrement à
table quand on connaît notamment la
compression des prix qui est effectué
sur le marché voilà donc les deux
questions je voulais vous poser des
questions sur finalement l'ex et abily
du modèle économique de l'utilisation de
l'hydrogène à la fois dans
l'aéronautique mais également dans le
transport routier
merci je vais d'un parole à monsieur
gold merci monsieur le président merci
aux différents intervenants à cette
réunion alors quand on parle du
développement de la filière hydrogène
c'est sur la mobilité et l'industrie que
sont orientées aujourd'hui des efforts
de recherche
la région auvergne rhône-alpes concentre
une grande partie de la filière
hydrogène en france les différents
acteurs avec le soutien des pouvoirs
publics ont lancé le projet zéro
émission de vallée afin d'alimenter 20
stations hydrogène vert et avec comme
objectif d'éviter 13000 tonnes de co2 et
l'utilisation de quatre millions trois
cent mille litres de diesel
ce projet a été financé par des fonds
européens est porté par un partenariat
public privé avec michelin la région et
la bande de territoire
à terme il s'agit de développer un
maillage suffisant à la station
hydrogène est de rendre la mobilité
accessible au plus grand nombre y
compris aux particuliers avec un coup
visé comparable à celui du diesel dans
le même ordre d'idée et même si vous
avez déjà en partie répondu on sait
combien le logement est source
d'émissions de co2 et de consommation
d'énergie
alors moi je voudrais vous demander s'il
est illusoire de penser que le
développement de la filière hydrogène
bas carbone pourrait se structure est
aussi un moyen terme autour du marché du
chauffage et la production d'eau chaude
domestique pour un développement massif
et avec des coûts évidemment plus
acceptable merci j'ai donné ma parole à
madame bonne foi puis après monsieur
jours pour clôturer cette première série
de questions oui merci monsieur le
président notre commission a récemment
créé une mission d'information relative
au transport de marchandises face aux
impératifs environnementaux dont je suis
rapporteur s'était dit tout à l'heure et
avec mon collègue rémy pointereau qui
est je crois présents dans l'hémicycle
le soutien à l'acquisition de véhicules
industriels à hydrogène est une des
mesures phares annoncées par le
gouvernement dans le cadre du plan de
relance afin d'accélérer
vernis cement de l'infini heures par
ailleurs le projet de loi climat intègre
également une incitation à cette
transition avec un soutien aux
transporteurs en contrepartie du
déremboursement progressif de la c2 la
tei cpe
néanmoins et ça a été rappelé par mon
collègue par mois de nombreux acteurs du
transport de marchandises considère que
le marché n'est pas mûr n'est pas mature
qu'il n'y a pas d'offre réaliste qui
puisse concurrencer les motorisations
fossiles et que en somme les bonus à
l'acquisition de véhicules hydrogène
relève aujourd'hui plutôt de l'affichage
fait justement est pour l'instant de
véhicules hydrogène alors donc selon
vous quelle échéance de compétitivité
des poids lourds à l'hydrogène est il
réaliste d'amorcer la transition du
secteur dès aujourd'hui ou bien est il
préférable d'investir dans des énergies
de transition comme des pions camions ce
qui nous a d'ailleurs été suggérée dans
nos auditions je vous remercie pour
votre réponse
si tu perds mais j'ai donné ma parole à
rémy pointereau augusto redonne la
parole tout de suite après comme on
parle de la mission transports en tant
que rapporteur missions transport est
d'après toi la parole merci merci
président effectivement avec nicole
bonnefoy nous menons cette mission sur
le transport des marchandises
face aux enjeux environnementaux et la
plupart des personnes que nous avons
auditionné des acteurs que nous avons
auditionné met en avant
l'hydrogène comme solution pour l'avenir
pour essayer de décarbonés donc tout ce
qui est transport de marchandise parce
que c'est vraiment là où se se passent
les choses et pour des cadeaux leur
monnaie ce secteur de transport
l'hydrogène possède certainement des des
propriétés intéressantes par rapport aux
carburants fossiles par contre il est
beaucoup plus inflammable et avec une
obligation d'avoir un stockage tout à
fait particulier est assez encombrant et
lourd pour les et le ferroviaire les
poids lourds et c'est donc moi ce que je
voulais savoir
selon vous est-ce que cette ce carburant
l'hydrogène est il compatible avec
l'utilisation de dans le cas de mobilité
notamment marchandises routier
marchandises ferroviaires et peut-être
demain l'aérien parce que bon c'est
peut-être une possibilité pour les rien
en mettant en face donc tous ces risques
que nous pouvons avoir sur loup
l'explosion lafleur a visité de ceux de
ce carburant
par contre que je voulais dire par
rapport à ce que ce qu'a dit mon
collègue monsieur de demi
sur le coup des poids lourds est
effectivement il ya peut-être un surcoût
mais le chiffre que tu donnais de 600000
ce sont pour des véhicules électriques
pour l'hydrogène n'y a pas eu de coups
mentionné sachant qu'un poids-lourd
classique coûte à peu près cent mille
cent mille euros 128 euros et qu'un
poids-lourd elektriks et 600000 euros
six cent mille euros donc c'est cinq
fois plus donc vous imaginez pour le
rentabiliser
il faut faire des à certain nombre de
kilomètres de milliers de kilomètres
supplémentaires
mais là le le sujet que nous avons c'est
le risque le risque que nous pouvons
avoir
en utilisant l'hydrogène sur des camions
où il ya des réservoirs très très
important de carburants fossiles est là
pour l'hydrogène ce sera des volumes
beaucoup beaucoup plus important donc
voilà c'est la question que je voulais
poser à l'ensemble des auditionnés merci
je vais pas rejoint avant de donner la
parole pour réponse oui président merci
messieurs vous avez déjà donné beaucoup
d'informations au sujet de l'hydrogène
mais moi je j'ai retenu de 3 2 3
questions plutôt précision que je
voudrais évoquer avec vous donc
l'hydrogène n'est pas à proprement
parler une source énergétique mais
plutôt ce qu'on appelle un vecteur
puisque comme vous l'avez dit il sert à
stocker transporter l'énergie produite
par une source pétrole photovoltaïque
charbon jusqu'à son utilisateur on le
considère comme propre puisque lors de
son utilisation il ne génère que seuls
deux lots comme comme déchets et n'émet
aucune émission gaz à effet de serre il
est donc propre en tant que transporteur
cependant l'énergie stocker et
transporter grâce à l'hydrogène provient
parfois et souvent vous l'avez dit donc
de sources fossiles
j'ai lu dans une étude du cabinet norton
rose
que en france 94 % de l'hydrogène
produit proviendrait aujourd'hui donc de
sources d'énergies fossiles alors
j'aimerais savoir si vous vous êtes fixé
une forme d'échéancier dans vos études
et analyses pour imaginer à quelle
échéance
on pourrait imaginer passer par exemple
à 50% ce que vous avez déjà un ordre
d'idée et puis d'abord me confirmer si
effectivement ce chiffre de 94 %
aujourd'hui est vrai merci j'ai lu
pardon j'ai une deuxième avec une
dérogation j'ai lu une 2 j'ai lu que
berlin en juin 2020 avait donc mis à
disposition un budget de 9 milliards
d'euros pour tout ce qui concerne
l'hydrogène et que la france elle va
investir 7 milliards sur dix ans et que
les discussions entre la france et
l'allemagne avaient lieu avaient
commencé alors est ce que l'objectif
c'est de mutualiser ce budget est de
faire un travail ensemble et de pousser
la recherche beaucoup plus loin et ou
alors chacun fait le job de son de son
côté donc je terminerai en vous
demandant comment réagissent les
pétroliers par rapport à ce
développement en cours et futurs du de
l'hydrogène vont-ils être des
partenaires vont ils s'impliquent est-ce
que vous avez des réponses à ce sujet
merci merci je vous donne la parole
monsieur booking
alors la question du
la question du camion est bien reconnue
nous avons au sein de france hydrogène à
un groupe de travail sur la mobilité en
général et en particulier sur les bus et
les camions
alors évidemment la question du coût est
fondamentale on a commencé sur les sur
les bus avec un objectif d'un plan mille
bus à l'horizon 2024
un peu aussi en ligne avec les jo de
2002 2024 à ce jour plus d'une vingtaine
de villes sont candidates à l'adoption
de flotte à hydrogène flotte de bus à
hydrogène citerai notamment dijon le
mans mais il y en a beaucoup d'autres il
ya une vingtaine en france
évidemment vous savez déjà que pau et
équipés et que dans le nord le syndicat
mixte des transports artois gohelle est
également équipé de bus français
d'ailleurs à hydrogène
alors c'est clair que le et on entame
également actuellement
travail sur les camions on est
clairement en retard va enfin en retard
enfin dans nos études sur le camion
parce qu'effectivement il ya très peu
d'offres à ce jour à ma connaissance à
par hyundai qui est en train de livrer
une série de cinq mille camions enfin un
grand nom c'est 5000 un puissant rebond
j'étais un peu mille six cents camions
mais entre disons les 50 premiers
camions voilà sont déjà été livrés ce
sont des camions pour la grande
distribution qui souhaitent décarbonés
également sa chaîne logistique
on a interrogé nous avons évidemment des
contacts avec la fntr et l'ensemble des
syndicats de transporteurs le tc au fond
comme y disent donc le coût total de
possession et quel que c'est un secteur
très compétitif très concurrentiel
pardon et le les coûts sont évidemment
la première le premier point d'attention
les transporteurs ne dise clairement
nous on veut bien aller à l'hydrogène
pour autant que ce ne fait pas une aux
ut co2 5% maximum mais en fait si c'est
zéro c'est encore évidemment beaucoup
mieux
donc là aussi nous commençons à agréger
des offres pour l'instant ils se
diraient ceux qui lèvent le doigt ce
sont surtout les collectivités pour
s'équiper en bennes à ordures on a à peu
près une vingtaine de
vingt ou trente bennes à ordures qui
seraient envisagées au niveau français
et vous avez également la société
cherokee a mis au point des remorques
frigorifiques à hydrogène
donc ça démarre mais je suis
complètement d'accord il ya pour
l'instant pas assez d'offres et là par
youn des bons il est qu il travaille il
réfléchit mais c'est encore assez
embryonnaire au savini vous avez la
société nicolas qui également travaille
là dessus vous avez daimler et volvo
trucks qui se sont alliées peu sur la
partie pile à combustible en restant
concurrents sur diront plusieurs laval
vous avez également une filiale de
renault qui s'appelle pays qui est qui
travaille également à la transformation
de deux véhicules le diesel vous pour
les adapter à l'électricité que ce soit
la batterie ou mais il ya bien sûr une
un effort à faire sur l'offre pour
l'instant il n'y a pas d'offre pourquoi
n'y a pas d'offres parce qu'il n'y a pas
de bon enfin bon on se mord un peu la
queue mais c'est quelque chose qui doit
monter en puissance le alors je vous
entends souvent insisté sur la recherche
pour réduire les coûts le évidemment je
l' ai déjà dit je le répète il faut
continuer à faire de la recherche
développement de l'innovation
mais la filière considère que ce n'est
que en changeant d'échelle en passeur à
des gigas factory qu'on va réduire les
coûts si je prends l'exemple de la demie
rails la muraille dont vous voyez
quelques exemplaires circuler dans paris
toyota est passé à 30 mille exemplaires
par an dans l'année dernière c'était
3000 exemplaires par an pour des boîtes
comme toyota c'est sur des chiffre
ridiculement bas ce n'est qu'en passant
à l'échelle industrielle par des séries
longues qu'on pourra réduire les coûts
et atteindre des coûts ya aucune raison
objective qu'un camion électrique soit
six fois plus cher qu'à camion diesel
c'est plutôt plus simple donc ça va être
le même prix voire moins cher simplement
il est fait en tellement petite série
que c'est très cher sur le sur la
question des quand va-t-on passer à 50%
de d'hydrogène bas carbone je dirais
nous avons répondu à cette question au
travers de du manifeste vous le trouver
sur notre site
le manifeste des choix vous le fournir
si vous le souhaitez
le le manifeste zorro publié en juillet
dernier se pose est justement la
question
que faut-il faire pour atteindre
l'objectif de l'article 20 de la loi
énergie climat
c'est à dire 20 à 40% d'hydrogène
décarbonés à l'horizon 2030
et donc nous avons trouvé que il faut
investir
gloor de 24 milliards un soutien global
de l'ordre de 10 milliards
quand je dis globale c'est à dire on n'a
pas fait parce qu'on n'était pas capable
de le faire le distinguo entre le
soutien des régions le soutien de
national le gouvernemental et le soutien
européen et pour ce faire donc mettre en
place 7000 mégawatts d'électrolysé qui
est quand même très proche des 6500 dont
parle la stratégie nationale donc de la
réponse c'est on arrive à 50% à
l'horizon 2030 pour autant que la
stratégie nationale
l'hydrogène est réalisée concernant le
france allemagne
donc vous avez noté que les ordres de
grandeur sur les mêmes entre ce que la
france et l'allemagne mettent ensemble
là encore j'ai entendu parler de
mutualiser la recherche bien sûr et ça
c'est fait déjà depuis longtemps au
travers
notamment des programmes européens dans
le cet acronyme barbare fc aj ou le fuel
cell hydrogen gender taking donc cette
ce partenariat public privé entre la
commission et les industriels et les
chercheurs au niveau européen pour
développer des programmes de recherche
au niveau européen et associer des
partenaires de tous les pays d'europe
donc ça ça marche ça va continuer pour
l'instant c'était horizons en vain va ça
va s'appeler maintenant horizon europe
c'est faux les fonds sont là et ça va
continuer s'agissant de la france et
l'allemagne
laurent michel l'évoqué d'auteur il y à
la mise la réflexion qui est déjà bien
avancée et une entente
disons une position commune adoptée est
présenté par l'elysée le 13 décembre
dernier une déclaration commune avec
donc du président macro et de l'après de
la chancelière merkel pour dire on est
favorable à un eeepc hui un projet
important d'attirer européen commun pour
donc mutualisé toujours la même question
mutualiser les besoins et gagner en
taille pour les projets qui vont qui
sont développés et par conséquent
réduire les coûts s'agissant de
l'hydrogène dans l'est dans les réseaux
c'est absolument fondamental d'avancé
également sur cette question et les que
ce soit les opérateurs gaziers du
transport de la distribution mais
également du stockage y travaille
ardemment ils ont déjà publié un rapport
que vous trouvez sur le net également
sur les conditions pour accueillir de
l'hydrogène dans les infrastructures
gazières
il s'agit c'est fondamental dans la
mesure où il s'agit de 7 et 6 tc un
vecteur énergétique et il va prendre la
même plat une place analogue à celle
qu'ont déjà l'électricité ou le gaz
naturel et donc il faut créer les
conditions du marché et donc mettre en
place l'infrastructure sous jacente qui
permet les échanges et donc le contact
entre les producteurs et les
consommateurs donc des travaux sur la
technologie elle-même tous les aciers
sont pas égaux pour accepter de
l'hydrogène donc des des également des
dispositifs réglementaires la qualité
pour l'instant la qualité n'est pas la
qualité
enfin disons le le taux d'hydrogène
admis si dans les réseaux n'est pas le
même d'un point à l'autre en europe
entre deux pays voisins les taux sont
pas les mêmes donc ça va poser des
problèmes de d'interopérabilité et donc
ces questions doivent être réglés et
troisièmement des problèmes d faut
résoudre également des questions d'ordre
régulatoire c'est à dire de quel est le
statut de ce réseau qui va transports
c'est l'hydrogène
j'ai tendance à penser que ça va être un
statut très proche de ce que ce qui est
fait pour le gaz naturel donc sans
aspirer clairement c'est à dire les
règles habituelles de l'axé laitière au
réseau que chacun puisse accéder au
réseau pour transporter sa marchandise
je dirais est également une séparation
des fonctions entre le commercialisateur
et le transporteur je terminerai sur les
pétroliers moi ce que je constate c'est
que les grands pétroliers s'y mettent
progressivement total donc maintenant
une business unit enfin une en une
entité qui s'occupe d'eux qu'ils
s'occupent hydrogène développée
l'hydrogène est totale en coopération
avec angie
travail sur sa raffinerie de la mède
dans le projet et massilia s'agit donc
de développer un parc de 100 mégawatts
de photovoltaïque et 40 mégawatts
d'électrolysé de façon à ils ont
introduire de l'hydrogène dans le
process de de la raffinerie de la mède
shell je veux citer quelques uns shell
est également très impliqué à la fois
dans le séraphine riz pour décarbonés le
l'hydrogène qui sert aux au raffinage du
pétrole mais également dans le dans des
consortiums notamment aux pays bas pour
développer de l'éolien qui permettra
donc d'avoir de l'énergie renouvelable
pour alimenter les électrolyseurs qui
vont produire l'hydrogène
après vous avez des déclarations de
président je pense au président de bp
donc là disons la percée surprenant là
c'est que les pétroliers donc prennent
le virage mon ce sont des gros bateaux
des gros donc les virages sont lents
mais là la progression peut être noté
voilà ce que je peux dire comme réponse
pour l'instant
monsieur michel par rapport aux
questions posées en complément la
première partie portait sur la
participation citoyenne
on dirait que comme sont nombreux sujets
énergétiques on peut avoir déjà
plusieurs échelles france qui il est
important que l'hydrogène soit dans les
débats sur l'énergie dans les futurs
débats parlementaires sur la loi de
programmation dans les concertations que
l'on mènera sur la future stratégie
nationale bat narbonne à programmation
pluriannuelle de l'énergie pour échanger
partager
après il ya la mise en oeuvre des
projets on peut le prendre d'abord sur
la question des grands cadres et je
reviendrai juste après sur la question
la sûreté est évident que les première
question qu'on peut se poser parmi les
premières c'est soit de manière générale
ou pour avoir des installations c'est
les nuits
danse où les risques donc ça veut dire
qu'on doit avoir à la fois un cadre
réglementaire clair mais aussi et donc
ça ça passe par des arrêtés ministériels
des directives précises mais aussi une
mise en oeuvre de qualité ce qui
sous-entend seulement que l'installation
fonctionne préconçues fonctionne
correctement mais aussi qu'il y as au
moment si on décide de créer un
électrolyseur ou d'injecter de
l'hydrogène dans des réseaux des
stations d'avitaillement il ya des
processus et des procédures c'est pas la
même chose mais il doit y avoir
effectivement appropriation par les
porteurs de projets de la nécessité non
seulement de conduire des processus
d'autorisation parle quand il y en a de
manière formelle mais de d'expliquer
concertée est aussi de rendre compte que
bah oui ça fonctionne qui a des
contrôles etc c'est important que les
projets quand elles sont menées soit
expliqué c'est aussi important c'est ce
qu'on voit dans l'appel à projet eco
systèmes territoriaux c'est que un
problème ne soit pas forcément plaquer
mais co construit avec des utilisateurs
l'hydrogène ce pas seulement un
électrolyseur ou un autre procédé qui
vient parler de l'hydrogène
c'est un ensemble d'usagé en liaison
avec les acteurs au delà de ça je ne
suis pas sûr que ça se distinguent
forcément de beaucoup d'autres sujets
dans le maine l'énergie ou veux parler
des éoliennes on peut parler des
méthaniseurs on peut parler de plein
d'autres sujets mais évidemment comme
c'est nouveau il ya besoin peut-être
encore plus d'appropriation et des
changes sur ces sujets sur la mobilité y
avait une question sur les modèles
économiques est d'abord sa seule origine
des subventions pour l'aviation alors
seul et le milliard 5 du programme sur
l'avion 50 millions viendra de la
stratégie l'hydrogène au titre du pays a
pour intention d'avenir le reste étant
sur les dispositifs spécifiques du plan
d'aidé plan sur l'aviation et du comité
de recherche aviation le corac donc
c'est pas 2 milliards dont 1 milliard 5
c'est 2 milliards + 1 milliard cinq
pales l'avion hydrogène n'ai pas compté
dans les deux milliards plan de relance
d'origine sauf pour 50 millions d'euros
je partage ce qui a été dit sur le
le transport routier effectivement
aujourd'hui les mots les motorisations
alternatives sûres en particulier le
poids lourd de transport de marchandises
sont encore peu nombreuses elles le sont
déjà mais sont beaucoup plus répandus
sur le bus
un bus électrique bus à hydro électrique
à prolongateur par piles à combustible
tout ça c'est déjà beaucoup plus
répandue mais l'offre n'est pas là mais
on croit qu'on vise du 2030 c'est à dire
qu'on y travaille aujourd'hui pour
déployer à cet horizon le transport
décarbonés et le transport décarbonée
c'est d'une part un transport plus
efficient lui-même c'est-à-dire soit on
transporte moins sur le transport plus
efficacement sur deux soit de 10 ans
sont à l'ombre des véhicules mieux
charger plus optimisé il ya ça que ce
soit décarbonés ou pas c'est la base et
après c'est le véhicule et son carburant
pour la première fois une législation
européenne qui fixe des objectifs aux
vendeurs de poids lourds de réduction
des émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
la flotte vendu environ qu'un 10 12 ans
après qu'ils aient eu les premiers
objectifs pour les véhicules légers donc
on suit ce chemin donc avec cet objectif
qui est fort et qui va nécessiter et
c'est en route que les transporteurs
avec des choix technologiques différents
qui s'offrent à eux certains sont un peu
multi vecteur d'autres ont une
focalisation développe ses poids lourds
donc c'est le soutien à la r&d et c'est
ensuite la massification qui devrait de
permettre de baisser les coûts à ce
stade
effectivement il ya un peu comme on l'a
fait le chemin pour les véhicules
électriques
il est effectivement des aides qui sont
peut-être qu'ils sont relativement
importantes à ses seins sur
amortissements froid de 30 ou 40 % plus
une aide qui vient d'être créé pour le
poids lourd hydrogène ou électrique de
50000 euros dans le cadre du plan de
relance
c'est à ça couvrant une partie
importante du surcoût évidemment ça ne
fait pas la masse puisque d'abord
l'offre n'est pas forcément là mais ça
permet quand même de lancer les premiers
démonstrateurs et qui sont importants
c'est un chemin qu'on a vu sur les
véhicules électriques légers
s'il n'avait pas eu quelques
constructeurs et quelques états dont la
france qui avait soutenu mordicus
pendant longtemps ce qui était ce qui
était confidentiel est ce que ça aurait
émergé
pas forcément et au moment au moment où
la réglementation devenait contraignante
on n'aurait pas eu la solution donc il
faut qu'ils aient quelque chose qui tire
est quelque chose qui pousse et on a
droit force on l'a vu sur les poids
lourds à gaz qui sont une première étape
eh bien il ya eu un moment où on a
soutenu l'achat de poids lourds c'est
encore le cas la mise en oeuvre de
stations d'avitaillement on en a
beaucoup et c'est un une piste y compris
avec le but le but et c'est enfin
évidemment travailler si on se lève tôt
jeunes pour que l'hydrogène que l'on met
dans le poids lourds soit moins cher
mais ça c'est vrai pour toutes les
utilisations de l'hydrogène alors sur le
chauffage cd et l'eau chaude sanitaire
qui est corrélé c'est des réflexions qui
existe dans plusieurs pays font entre
autres aux pays bas et au royaume uni
qui ont fondé démonstrateur avec là
aussi plus plusieurs souces option s'est
mélangé ses hydrogène mélangé au réseau
de gaz ou même convertir le réseau de
gaz à l'hydrogène et il est assez connu
khalid s'il ya un club de foot mais
aussi un réseau de gaz qui est en train
de se convertir à l'hydrogène mais
en dehors de ça c'est on en est au stade
démonstrateur néanmoins sarr posera les
questions de la l'équation énergétique
et économique qu' il peut y avoir dans
quelles que soient les procédés quand
même pas mal de pertes à force
d'utiliser de convertir l'énergie en
hydrogène et un certain nombre d'experts
ne sont pas ne pense pas mais on va voir
ce que donne si les les divers travaux
de r&d peut il ya un gros avantage
focalisé l'hydrogène sur le chauffage
je ne tirerai pas un trait néanmoins
définitif sur cette option mais elle
n'apparaît pas forcément parmi les plus
prometteuses mais la question des
objectifs a été posée était entre autres
1 il ya un mot d'ordre mais je confirme
que la loi énergie climat fixe un
objectif de 20 40 % de nerfs dans
l'hydrogène
aujourd'hui et industriels et si vous
vous portez un peu plus loin avec le les
2000 les 600000 tonnes qu'on produirait
en 2030 ça ferait un peu plus de 60% de
l'hydrogène aujourd'hui utilisée en 2030
qui aura sûrement un usage plus gros
donc on sera peut-être dans ces eaux de
40 à 50% seraient déjà quand même non
négligeable et la cité les montants
d'investissement et les gigawatts
d'électro liste concon mais derrière
pour finir sur une des dernières
questions
c'était le cadre de sûreté il
effectivement est extrêmement important
pour les installations de production et
de stockage et distribution y compris
quand on veut le passé par les réseaux
et les véhicules
ce sont des activités qui sont en france
en europe et dans le monde fortement
réglementé avec que sur l'hydrogène ou
tout autre fluide valu une approche
génériques sur quels sont les risques
et quels sont les les mesures pour les
prévenir et des processus en grosse
maille un peu partout dans le monde
les installations de production ou de
stockage ce sont les équivalents des
installations classées pour la
protection de l'environnement s'appelle
ailleurs ailleurs différemment ailleurs
mais c'est comme ça quand c'est gros
c'est soumis à autorisation parfois même
outil de directive seveso autorisation
explicite et avec une réglementation à
doc par arrêté préfectoral si c'est
moins gros on va cas des petites
stations service jusqu'à une simple
déclaration mais avec des prescriptions
et comme j'ai dit récemment je pensais
en 2018 nous avons adapté nos collègues
de la direction générale de la
prévention des risques qui gère ce
domaine adapter la réglementation
stations service comme on l'avait
d'ailleurs déjà adapté au fait que
maintenant il faut aussi avoir des
bornes de recharge de véhicules
électriques dans les stations-service
question de cohabitation des usages il
faut trouver le bon degré de l'équilibré
entre la une sécurité très forte
évidemment la praticabilité des choses
se mettaient un bancaire autour de toute
chose c'est très sûr mais s'il ya un
bain claire autour de votre station
service on n'y va pas donc il faut mais
sable ça et c'est vraiment très prise en
compte et par ailleurs sur les véhicules
on a aussi évidemment des cadres
d'homologation des véhicules dans le
cadre avec un chapeau faîtier c'est un
des il y en a quand même quelques
domaines c'est spécifiquement absolue
l'automobile il ya un cadre onusien de
la réception des véhicules ensuite
déclinée au niveau européen ou en groupe
les grandes séries sont réceptionnés par
son acception par type par une autorité
européenne on en a en france qui est
rattaché à notre direction générale et
ils peuvent ensuite circuler dans toute
l'europe
la réception est reconnue et après il ya
des sous préfets cependant pour quand il
ya des toutes petites séries va y avoir
des réceptions y compris jusqu'à une
réception individuelle d'un véhicule
mais le véhicule hydrogène comme
d'autres à pétrole à gas & electric fait
l'objet de ces réceptions basé sur des
dossiers réglementaires très lourd mais
aussi des essais
est extrêmement pointue et on a déjà
aujourd'hui un certain nombre de
véhicules à hydrogène homologué par des
constructeurs et étrangers 20 entre
autres japonais
mollo gare d'europe mais les camions
hyundai qu'on évoque effectivement eux
aussi sont homologués on a des bus à
hydrogène homologué en france et du
constructeur français
donc c'est un sujet extrêmement
important et qui nous amène évidemment
dans le cadre de tous ces processus à
prendre en compte les nouvelles
technologies adapter nos outils et
approches des essais l'homologation des
véhicules avec le nouveau fluide sans
compter ne le fait que parfois ces
véhicules un jour deviendront autonomes
ou ou un peu plus autonome
ce qu'on doit prendre en compte aussi
dans dippach ce n'est pas un sujet c'est
un sujet important mais qui a je pense à
des processus il s'inscrit dans des
processus très normé et où on a
l'habitude de voir des nouvelles
technologies et émerger ça va même après
on a eu à traiter des questions peut-on
autoriser des véhicules électriques dans
des parkings souterrains voilà c'est
mais c'est une des préoccupations
extrêmement importante et au quotidien
il trouve par ailleurs c'est il ya là il
ya la même chose mutatis mutandis pour
des bateaux et des avions par ailleurs
il se trouve que par ailleurs notre
ministère non seulement à chercher la
politique énergétique mène toutes ces
politiques de sûreté de ses véhicules ce
qui facilite un peu la connexion pour le
travail
merci merci il ya plus une question fort
à préciser tout à l'heure c'est la seule
réponse à notre question d'autant que la
conjointe qui avait évoqué les 7
milliards investis en france et les 9
milliards en allemagne
et puis savoir si et bien ce serait
commun ou pas si chacun va mène sa
politique dans ce serait peut-être bien
vous y répondiez avant que je donne la
parole à une deuxième série de questions
je croyais avoir répondu en disant que
c'est pas bien percuté alors voilà je
disais que donc la france amie 7,2
milliards l'allemagne c'est 9 milliards
dont 2 milliards pour des coopérations
pour importer de l'hydrogène des pays
voisins de l'europe et je disais que la
coopération elle existe déjà en termes
de recherche développement au niveau
européen dans le cadre du fc aj udu ce
partenariat public privé qui travaille
sur la recherche et la mise en place de
démonstration le développement de
l'innovation relatives à l'hydrogène
dans toute l'europe et en particulier
donc dé coopération entre la france et
l'allemagne
et ce sur quoi on travaille actuellement
et je cite et donc le communiqué de
l'elysée du 13 décembre dernier donc
à la suite d'une visite de madame merkel
me semble-t-il où il est avait été dit
que la france et l'allemagne étaient en
faveur d'un de la mise en oeuvre d'un
projet important d'intérêt européen
commun en anglais un ipsey importante
project of common d'europe en titre
reste pour justement mettre en oeuvre
des gigas factory à l'instar de ce qui
s'est fait pour les batteries et pour
justement massifier la production et
réduire les coûts
merci messieurs treiner si vous avez
juste un point beaucoup de choses ont
été dites sur quelqu'un avait posé la
question du rendement global de power to
gas to power et avec un chiffre de
l'ordre de 25% ont effectivement c'est
ça 25 % les possibilités d'amélioration
c'est peut-être 30 35%
donc vous dites que c'est mieux que ça
ok 3 5%
ça veut dire que pour déstocker 1 il
faut avoir ce qe 3 donc ça s'affiche un
peu les limites je crois de l'exercice
en tout cas ça donne le bonheur de
grandeur mais ça veut dire que si vous
lui en faire beaucoup il faut avoir des
sources d'énergie dédié à ça de la même
façon que si vous voulez je prendrai
l'exemple tout à l'heure de d'avoir 20 %
de l'énergie finale avec de l'hydrogène
s'est augmenté de 50% la production
d'électricité voire de 100 % suivant le
scénario énergétique l'on considère donc
ça c'était un premier point le deuxième
point que
de complément j'ai oublié mais c'est pas
grave ça reviendra merci monsieur michel
rollier a complété en étant totalement
raccord avec ce que dit monsieur
boucliers l'idée soit des premières et d
amont soit des eeepc oui c'est bien
d'additionner les efforts avec des
acteurs des deux pays et les
financements dip et celui non non c'est
un financement commission européenne et
le ou les deux ou trois ou plus
pays concernés donc on a eu déjà
plusieurs réunions des changes sous
forme
on pourrait presque dire speed dating de
mise en relation franco allemande sur ce
sujet maintenant on rentre dans la phase
d'appropriation et d'examen des projets
mais on n'est pas dans une situation
privilégiée mais pas exclusive on a fait
le même exercice
il ya une dizaine de jours une première
réunion avec nos homologues italiens
temps il nous étions par les industriels
des deux pays
les ministères de l'économie et de la
facture énergétique en france et le
ministère italien où l'énergie étant
dans le même lit sable économies là bas
dont et on a donc on a aussi initié ce
travail avec l'italie et ce n'est pas
formelle selon c'est déjà un franc il y
a déjà des acteurs français présents en
italie et et inversement on a des enfin
beaucoup d'acteurs et étaient présents
donc on vise à un moment c'est pas le
très pin est à dire l'europe l'europe
comme dieu sait si on arrive à faire
émerger et comme ça coûte quand même
relativement cher et que c'est pas gagné
technologiquement on on pense aux
affaires des électrolyseurs très
performant dans le futur et moins chère
à tous mais si c'est quand même pas
évident donc si on arrive à joindre les
efforts à la fois au plan financier et
industriel
ça sera important après il y aura il est
évident aussi qu'il ya des stratégies
légèrement différente
et puis des camps fait des écosystèmes
territoriaux sauf s'ils sont
transfrontaliers ils sont soit français
soient allemands évidemment et mais je
pense que tous ces échanges
au delà même des projets en commun tous
ces échanges ils permettront de nourrir
les politiques des uns et des autres
parce qu'il n'y a pas de raison qu'on
fasse pire que l'allemagne a dit qu'elle
fasse pire que nous ayons un versement
merci pour ces précisions je donne la
parole à main préville
merci monsieur le président merci
messieurs pour vos interventions et vous
éclairage alors d'abord je voudrais
revenir sur des choses qui ont été
évoqués par diverses personnes sur les
projections qu'on pourrait faire sur
l'avenir bien évidemment ces projections
le dans l'état actuel des choses ne
peuvent pas se faire si on tient compte
que on pourrait réduire aussi à la
consommation d'énergie et vous l'avez
évoqué on pourrait réduire aussi la
production d'engrais qui consomme de
l'hydrogène
parce que c'est quand même un petit peu
prévu dans nos projections d'avenir
et puis parce que quand on a je voudrais
revenir aussi là dessus quand on a deux
d'heuliez de les énergies renouvelables
qui sont produites par des éoliennes par
exemple alors que il y à une demande
très faible voire nulle de les utiliser
c'est peut-être intéressant justement
d'utiliser ces énergies là pour
fabriquer pour faire de produire de
l'hydrogène
également je reviens sur quelque chose
qui a été évoqué c'est à dire sur les
conversions d'énergie effectivement à
chaque fois qu'on va découvrir qu'il ya
une conversion il ya des pertes
d'énergie mais je pense moi que pour les
électrolyseurs on est en passe quand
même de faire des progrès significatifs
alors moi j'aurais voulu vous demander
puisque on a parlé de mobilité lourde et
qu'on a
en france on n'a pas trop parlé des
trains on en prévoit en france de
remplacer nos nos véhicules diesel fans
au nôtre un diesel par des trains à
hydrogène et qu'il y a un petit peu
urgence en la matière parce que les
trains à hydrogène circule déjà depuis
trois ans en allemagne et qu'on pourrait
quand même s'attendre à ce que ça prenne
vraiment que ce soit vraiment maintenant
quelque chose de concret en france et
que ce soit cette manière très
significative donc où en est-on et à
quel horizon va-t-on avoir des trains à
hydrogène et notamment pour remplacer
tous ses trains qui consomment encore du
fonctionnent au diesel
deuxième chose sur le sur le les avions
sur les projets que airbus et il me
semble et qui sont déjà très avancés
également sur l'hydrogène vert alors
produit par une part des énergies
renouvelables ou pas certes mais il faut
quand même tenir compte du fait que on
va baisser notre production nucléaire et
que nos centrales sont vieillissantes et
qu'il ne faut qu on pas qu à nouveau en
prennent du retard
si on table là dessus en se disant on va
utiliser cette cette électricité là pour
faire de l'hydrogène vert et ne pas
développer suffisamment comme les autres
pays
la production d'hydrogène vert avec les
nerfs donc attention à ne pas passer à
côté sur les alors j'ai une question qui
n'a pas été évoqué jusqu'à présent et
sur les besoins de formation
d'ingénieurs de techniciens et
d'ouvriers qui travailleront sur ces
écosystèmes
est-ce que c'est prévu est ce qu'il ya
des formations qui sont prévus pour pour
faire en sorte que l'on ne soit pas à
nouveau freiné parce qu'on n'aura pas
les on n'aura pas des les les emplois
qu'ils pourront faire en sorte qu'on
puisse avancer sur ce sujet je vous
remercie
merci monsieur villé
merci monsieur le président alors pour
revenir sur la notion d'objectif donc
contrairement à l'union européenne la
france ne s'impose aucun objectif dont
concernant le nombre de tonnes
d'hydrogène décarbonés et donc à ce
titre notre ambition peut manquer de
lisibilité et surtout de partage d'enjeu
et d'objectifs à l'échelle des
collectivités des territoires ou d'un
certain nombre de parties prenantes
j'aimerais avoir votre opinion donc sur
le sujet qu'elle planification pour le
développement de l'hydrogène vert alors
le haut commissariat au plan est il
aujourd'hui directement concernés est ce
qu'il ya une réflexion donc pour
mobilier se mobiliser sur ses politiques
est ce que vous avez donc des éléments
précis sur ce sujet là donc long terme
de planification pendant le maillage
territorial de production d'hydrogène
peu ce truc peut se structurer où doit
se structurer
quelle perte en arias quel partenariat
avec les régions
faut-il inscrire des objectifs de
développement d'hydrogène dans l'estrade
est donc dans les documents aussi de
planification à l'échelle des régions
et faut-il aussi les décliner par
exemple au niveau des plans climat air
énergie territoriaux pour faire en sorte
que les territoires s'empare aussi de
cette problématique de ses objectifs et
s'engage notamment dans le cas des
politiques d'appels à projets et puis
pour terminer justement vous avez
beaucoup évoqué les appels à projets
c'est une excellente chose pour
progresser et avancer
mais tout le déploiement de ces
politiques ne peut pas reposer
uniquement sur les appelle la poule h
d'un projet d'où l'intérêt aussi d'avoir
une vision de planification et de
coordination notamment avec les
collectivités territoriales
merci et l'invitant à parole à louis
jean de nicolay qui nous entend merci
vraiment l'essentiel des questions ont
déjà été posées moi si vous le permettez
je voudrais revenir sur les programmes
co construit notamment avec les
territoires
je voudrais prendre l'exemple si vous le
permettez de ce qui se passe dans la
salle avec le mans métropole est une
entreprise s'appelle kaikai rose qui
voudrait produire à partir du pétrole
des premiers roulages de pyrolyse de gaz
naturel qui est grâce à la méthanisation
agricole qui semble aussi être
une alternative je crois que c'est une
d'après ce qu'on me dit c'est une
technologie qui semble inédite en europe
alternative et complémentaire à
l'électrolysé de l'eau et qui serait
produit aussi massivement par
l'hydrogène père c'est un procès de
qualification à très haute température
qui est duplicable et adaptable sur les
territoires ruraux et en utilisant la
biomasse et avicoles lepreau le projet
prévoit une centaine d'agriculteurs à
travers le centre qui pourrait produire
ainsi cette méthanisation qu'elle est
quel est l'avis de deux de nos
interlocuteurs sur cette prise de
conscience à la fois agricole et sur
l'implication de l'agriculture dans le
processus diderot ciel je crois que
l'agriculture eiffel pour produire des
aliments mais aussi produire de
l'énergie
quel est selon eux le le pourcentage que
pourrait apporter la vie culture dans ma
participation à la production
d'hydrogène
merci merci chers collègues la parole
est un monsieur chevrollier où les merci
monsieur le président merci aux
intervenants de cette tableront sur
l'hydrogène pour la transition
écologique moi je voulais revenir sur la
thématique du climat les objectifs
climat que nous devons avoir cinq ans
après les accords de paris cette année
là la coop 26 à glasgow il faut des
politiques publiques pour décarbonés
notre économie vous vous en avait parlé
la coop 26 le royaume uni envisage -68%
des gaz à effet de serre par rapport à
1990 temps des objectifs extrêmement
ambitieux donc nous on a la stratégie
nationale hydrogène avec un conseil
national de l'hydrogène vous en avez
parlé et vous avez parlé également de du
nucléaire et ma joie que vous précisiez
vraiment vos positions sur le
l'importance de la filière nucléaire
pour le déploiement de cette filière
hydrogène dans notre pays si on veut
obtenir des
des résultats sur le terrain climatique
où il y a urgence climatique est
aujourd'hui un jugement du tribunal
administratif sur sur la nécessité
d'agir dans le domaine climatique donc
on a un besoin de long terme mais aussi
a besoin de d'action court terme et donc
la place du nucléaire
et puis j'aurai une deuxième question
qui recoupent celles qui viennent d'être
posées notamment sur la déclinaison
territoriale qui a une stratégie
nationale et à teillé déclinaison
territoriale avec les régions l'ensemble
des régions s'engagent sur l'hydrogène
dans ma région des pays de la loire
également mais de l'argent et après il
faut le le déploiement territorial donc
quels sont vos réflexions sur le
déploiement territorial pour la mise en
oeuvre du de l'hydrogène et notamment de
façon très pratique avec le maillage de
stations hydrogène sur notre territoire
merci oui
la parole est à mes yeux le dantec merci
merci monsieur le président c'est
toujours un débat absolument
extraordinaire quand on se projette
comme ça sur l'énergie qu'on voit bien
qu'en fait on est dans un système
matriciel avec pas mal d'inconnues
puis les uns les autres font bouger deux
ou trois variables et arrivent à des
solutions en diamétralement opposées
donc moi ma première question ça serait
votre avis sur le moment où on pourra
arrêter une stratégie puisqu'on a bien
compris pour l'instant n'est pas au
stade de la stratégie on est au stade de
l'exploration des différents systèmes
qui cohabitent
on a baissé sur les l'hydrogène sur le
renouvelable sur différents types de
mobilité
tout ça en fait ne fait pas une
stratégie on est au stade de
l'exploration donc à votre avis à quel
moment ces questions pour vous 3 qui
concerne à la fois l'état les
industriels
on aura une vision suffisante des
principaux paramètres parks carbone prix
de production de renouvelables prédisait
le thriller qui fera qu'on pourra aller
vraiment à une stratégie comme on en a
eu en france dans les années 70 et on en
a plus aujourd'hui non pas contre
à bord mais on a trop d'inconnues sur
les paramètres première question est la
deuxième vous en avez un tout petit peu
parlé et ça me semble pourtant être une
des questions clés aujourd'hui c'est qui
produit l'électricité
c'est à dire très clairement on a peu
parlé le photovoltaïque la mède par
exemple le projet angie total à la mède
c'est du photovoltaïque sur la
production électrique sources pour
l'hydrogène décarbonés et ce qu'on voit
aujourd'hui aussi avec le projet d'edf à
dubai
c'est qu'on arrive à du 11 euros le
mégawattheure 11 euros le mégawattheure
pour comparer une clé pas une c'est
plutôt 120 130 euros le mégawattheure
nucléaire donc le marché est en train de
trancher et c'est plutôt le
photovoltaïque qui est de très loin le
moins cher et qui rompt y compris
l'hydrogène un compétitif mais il faut
des surfaces au sol considérable ce qui
fait que les grands producteurs demain
un d'électricité et peut-être
d'hydrogène ou pas parce que ça peut
aussi être des câbles qui franchissent
la méditerranée seront ceux qui ont
beaucoup de sol et beaucoup de soleil et
donc notamment les pays désertiques
c'est le sens de l'investissement d'edf
qui se chiffre en milliards sur sur
dubaï par exemple donc est ce que vous
ne pensez pas que ce qui est une pièce
importante de ce puzzle c'est aussi la
production massive d'électricité
photovoltaïque demain des pays notamment
sahéliens et désertique
merci j'ai donné ma parole à martin
décidera qui est puis à didier bolelli
pour conclure merci mais c'est sur
l'éducation
merci messieurs pour toutes vos
interventions très intéressante moi je
vais en fait être un peu dans la
continuité de ce qui vient de vous être
ont posé comme question
c'est à dire je formule est un peu
différemment au niveau 2
on a bien vu que l'hydrogène il ya un
véritable engouement aujourd'hui il y as
et cela ne date pas d'aujourd'hui vous
allez même fait des citations monsieur
treiner qui date d'un petit moment
donc tout ça pour dire que la vertu
d'une certaine manière de l'hydrogène a
l'air d'être dû accepter toutefois quel
est selon vous chacun de vous dans vos
dans vos responsabilités l'enjeu réel
que vous y voyez est-il essentiellement
économique et elles essentiellement
environnementale et il essentiellement
souverainiste puisque on a tous très
bien compris que ce n'est au fond on
parle d'un vecteur énergétique
on ne fera pas l'économie à un moment
donné d'avoir le débat sur la source
même de nos énergies électriques
et puis on voit bien que même
l'hydrogène à des couleurs il est gris
bleu vert jaune
donc tout cela mérite un petit peu
peut-être un moment donné qu'on
élargisse le débat sur la source même de
cet hydrogène et j'ai une deuxième
remarque en fait pour vous monsieur
treiner je suis un peu resté sur ma faim
à un moment donné dans vos propos vous
avez rappelé évidemment les fluctuations
qui peut y avoir et que nos
installations aujourd'hui ne nous
permettent pas par rapport à l'hydrogène
vers d'absorber
d'absorber en réalité cette production
d'hydrogène vert si j'ai bien compris en
raison de l'intermittence de l'éolien ou
du solaire
et puis surtout vous avez parlé d'
incohérences en disant qu'il y avait un
certain nombre d'incohérences
aujourd'hui dans le débat autour de
l'hydrogène donc moi ça m'a un petit peu
intrigué pour ne rien vous cacher
j'aurais souhaité d'autant plus que nos
deux autres interlocuteurs monsieur
michel monsieur clique n'ont pas rebondi
là dessus j'aurais souhaité vous vous
posez la question très simplement
est-ce que c'est au niveau de la source
est ce que c'est au niveau de
l'hydrogène lui-même à quelques elles
sont j'ai bien compris que c'était vaste
qu'on ne pourrait pas en débattre ce
matin mais où situez-vous ces
incohérences aujourd'hui dans le débat
de l'hydrogène merci didier marie
merci monsieur le président je voudrais
revenir sur ce que nous avions intérêt
dans le cadre de la loi d'orientation
des mobilités avec un point très précis
mais qui peut être déterminant et
notamment pour un grand nombre de start
up c'est la possibilité de faire ce
qu'on appelle le retrofit vers la
transformation sur des véhicules
existants ce qui évite les les mises à
la casse le changement intempestif de
véhicules qui pourraient servir beaucoup
plus longtemps donc on l'avait intégré
pour les véhicules automobiles et le
décret du 13 mars dernier permet de fait
d'intégrer cette technologie ou cette
possibilité pour les véhicules tous les
véhicules de plus de 5 ans un moteur
thermique
ce qui veut dire que par exemple travaux
publics dans l'attraction agricole
dans un certain nombre de domaines et
notamment les poids lours était évoqué
tout à l'heure puisque un poids lourd en
construction naf coûte excessivement
cher
nous avons aujourd'hui la possibilité ça
existe des startups ont mis en place
cette technologie y compris sur du poids
lourd et du tracteur agricole sur des
bennes à ordures ménagères également que
vous évoquez je cite l'exemple d'une
société de petites sociétés en vendée
qui qui pratique et qui fait sur demande
ce genre de de transfert de technologie
à la fois sur l'électrique et sur la
pile à combustible
donc c'est à mon sens une solution qui
n'est pas évidemment de masse mais qui
pourrait répondre au double souci à la
fois de d'avoir évidemment l'énergie
propre décarbonés et en même temps
d'éviter de mettre à la casse ou d'aller
envoyés sur des marchés extérieurs des
produits ou des engins qui sont plus
polluants que ce que nous souhaitons
voir évoluer
il ya le projet ait il je sais pas si
vous avez entendu parler donc c'est un
groupement qui se forme et qui cherche à
monter un projet pour l'instant c'est 95
gigawatts 95 gigawatts de renouvelables
essentiellement du photovoltaïque en
espagne avec l'installation de soixante
sept gigawatts de d'électro lice pour
produire 4000 de l'ordre de 4 millions
de tonnes d'hydrogène à l'horizon 2030
l'a apparemment compte tenu des coûts
vous si c'est alors dans la péninsule
ibérique du photovoltaïque à 10 15 euros
du mégawattheures semble accessible
il faut encore que les par la
massification les coûts des
électrolyseurs baisse on est
actuellement de l'ordre de chopin à 800
de l'ordre de 800 kg kilowatts que 2 800
euros du kilo watt paraît que ça tombe
dans les 300 euros des kilowatts
ça semble accessible si on fait des
gigas factory d'électrolyseurs donc tout
ça se met en place mais il faut dans le
même temps qu'eux
l'ensemble des clients possible je pense
à la sidérurgie je pense à la chimie je
pense à deux donc c'est disons ces
écosystèmes territoriaux qui vont
absorber de l'hydrogène soit pour la
mobilité lourde soit pour des usages
industriels plus diffus comme tous à se
mettre en place et que l'infrastructure
de transport se met également en place
je suis désolé les leggings gazoduc pour
l'instant son plein d'hydrogène sont
plaints de gaz naturel il faut déjà que
les consommations de gaz naturel le bes
pour pouvoir réutiliser pour le pour le
gaz pour le l'hydrogène pour alors la
question de la il y avait une question
sur la biomasse là aussi je crois y
avait a répondu dans mon propos
liminaire en disant que pour nous
l'enjeu il est la stratégie affichée le
8 septembre dernier d'un clairement là
disons met clairement en avant la
production d'hydrogène par par
électrolyse
mais nous disons qu'il ya d'autres
façons de faire de l'hydrogène et
notamment à partir de la biomasse
que ce soit à partir du chanvre comme
kairos le le proposent soit partir des
écorces de de bois enfin il ya des
procédés type la société haffner à
vitry-le-françois développe ce genre de
deux projets et va l'implanter très
prochainement à strasbourg il ya des
projets de pyrogazéification qui
permettent également de produire de
l'hydrogène donc il n'y a pas que
l'électro lise à partir d'électricité
renouvelable mais il ya également
d'autres types d'électricité est
également la biomasse sur le concernant
la mobilité de lourdes le le manifeste
que nous avions produit au mois deux
mois de juillet dernier
parler de 250 trains bon vous avez vu le
une étude de l'ademe qui vient de sortir
qui parle de 250 à 300 trains qui
pourrait passer à l'hydrogène dans l'est
dans l'est dans le futur alors
effectivement on peut on peut se dire
pourquoi en france est aussi lent alors
que l'allemagne a déjà acheté 14 rames
que l'italie est également s'équipent en
train à hydrogène de fabrication
française alstom
je pense que c'est à voir dans la
relation entre les régions l'état
la sncf et alstom enfin disons il ya ces
relations qui sont sûrement à clarifier
mais je pense que vous êtes plus à même
que moi de de comprendre ses relations
entre ces quatre quatre acteurs mais en
tout cas le train et en étant est en
cours de mise au point
sa spécificité par rapport au train
allemand sait qu'il sera bi mode c'est à
dire qu'il pourra à la fois les sur les
lignes caténaires il aura un pantographe
et et les lignes non électrifiées ski de
ce qui exige des développements un peu
supérieur à ce que
un peu plus longue que ce qui a été fait
pour l'allemagne je crois savoir que
l'occitanie à commander ces premières
ces premières rames et donc les choses
se mettent en place
dernier point je voudrais évoquer c'est
la formation
donc je les dis également il ya là un
sujet important de dison de d'identifier
les compétences nécessaires et mettre en
place les formations là aussi donc nous
y travaillons au sein de france
hydrogène en lien avec un certain nombre
de régions il ya notamment en normandie
l'agglomération kosen agglo donc le pays
de caux qui y travaillent mais il ya
l'occitanie travaille également en fin
donc on est en train de faire un
recensement de ski de ce qui se fait
pour voir s'il ya des trous dans la
raquette et s'il faut développer ces
formations c'est un sujet bien
identifiés sur lequel nous travaillons
monsieur michel monsieur trenet mais les
le veut bien voir l'introduction n'était
pas inutile
il ya beaucoup de l'image d'epinal
concernant l'énergie et notamment
l'électricité et je voudrais revenir là
dessus sur la gestion du futur je prends
un peu dans le désordre sur la gestion
des fluctuations à l'heure actuelle les
les renouvelables en france sont son fa
leurs fournitures sais mais c'est
marginal
donc on peut très bien gérer les
fluctuations avec ce qu'on a
2 pilotable avec avec l'hydraulique avec
le gaz un peu de gain d'un peu de
charbon etc
la question c'est si on envisage une
forte pénétration des renouvelables
intermittentes dans ce cas là les
fluctuations sont de l'ordre de elles
sont supérieures à la puissance moyenne
elles sont deux pour le pour le solaire
elles sont sales à entre 0 la nuit et
puis une fraction notable de la
puissance installée le jeu
et pour l'éolien encore une fois ça
varie entre quelques % de la puissance
installée et 60 70 % de puissance
installée
donc vous ne gérez pas ces fluctuations
avec le système actuel est ce que c'est
possible avec des batteries est ce que
c'est possible de l'hydrogène la réponse
pour moi clairement c'est non mais pour
ça il faut dédier une séance à
l'électricité et ses affaires les règles
de trois et puis voir comment ça
fonctionne on peut pas je peux pas vous
le dire comme ça mais ce que ce qui est
clair ce qui doit être clair là c'est
que gérer les fluctuations de la demande
d'électricité
c'est une chose gérer les fluctuations
de la production d'électricité quand il
ya une forte pénétration de ressources
intermittente
c'en est une autre c'est un autre
problème il faut le regarder faire les
rec 2 3 et voir ce qui sort et je vois
là je prends une demi-heure et puis je
vous montre que sans doute sa naissance
ça n'arrivera pas bon alors ça a des
répercussions évidemment sûr qu'on voit
à travers le rapport de rte
sur les trois scénarios de production
d'hydrogène et on voit bien que c'est en
ayant de l'électricité peu cher et avec
un fort
le facteur de charge le plus élevé
possible que le prix est le plus bas et
donc ça veut dire l'électricité du
réseau et je pense que c'est ça qui va
se faire
le en parlant de stratégie il ya un
élément de stratégie qui est clair c'est
le remplacement de l'hydrogène
industrielles utilisant l'industrie le
shimmy les engrais etc
ça c'est clair ensuite sur la mobilité
moi je mettrai un point d'interrogation
parce que vous avez raison je crois que
c'est pas encore tranché il faut
regarder enfin il ya des tas de choses
c'est vraiment un sujet qu'on peut pas
traiter uniquement par par l'hydrogène
il faut regarder l'ensemble des trucs et
puis sur le troisième dossier
c'est-à-dire la gestion des fluctuations
des intermittents avec l'hydrogène
alors c'est pas deux points
d'interrogation de jeu mais c'est un
point d'exclamation ninon ça n'arrivera
jamais ça n'arrivera pas on va pas
augmenter la production de l'hydrogène
avec des sources d'électricité
fluctuante
écoutez on a à côté de nous un grand
pays industriel qui a installé 70 awa de
photovoltaïque 70 à wade au lien ils ont
doublé leur puissance installée
ils ont rien diminué de la puissance
pilotable en faisant tout ça ça leur a
coûté 350 milliards d'euros
ça doit monter dans la décennie à 500
milliards d'euros si une étude de
l'université düsseldorf et ça produit
25% de l'électricité à un prix pour les
particuliers qui est double du prix
français et qui est il ya des gens qui
imaginent qu avec ça si c'était une
piste crédible mais ils le feraient
puisque ils veulent développer une
demande pour l'hydrogène de véhicules
hydrogène mais ils disent explicitement
l'hydrogène nous allons lâcheté ailleurs
or si c'était une piste crédible ils le
feraient ils démarrèrent qui
commencerait on verrait quelque chose on
ne le voit pas donc c'est vraiment des
images d'epinal ça ne se passera pas bon
alors du point de vue de deux points
encore sur l'hydrogène vert du point de
vue climat l'hydrogène n'a pas de
couleur il est décarbonée ou carbonées
points donc il faut il faut à mon sens
il faut parler en termes de décarboner
carbonnel décarbonés et puis voilà c'est
tout il n'ya pas de verres gris machin
truc c'est ça c'est du détail de la
fabrication ça n'a aucune incidence sur
le climat le climat ne voit pas ça il
voit ainsi ses émetteurs de co2 c'est
pas un émetteur de co2 voilà bon et puis
alors sûr c'est très intéressant ça la
question sur le jeu sait plus qui a posé
la question sur l'angleterre qui a
diminué ses émissions de gaz à effet de
serre c'était vous oui alors
effectivement il ya des choses très très
amusante là dessus qu'ils sont très
intéressantes et qu'on peut que je
voudrais pas en prenant le la relation
pub énergie vous savez si vous regardez
la corrélation entre le pipe et
l'énergie mondiale vous avez une droite
et ça s'explique de façon extrêmement
simple en termes physiques c'est que
nous vivons de transformer la matière
tout ça c'est à matière transformer
l'ordinateur les machins les tricks et
françois sont la matière toute
transformation de la matière du point de
vue physique
un bilan énergétique ou peut lui donner
un bilan énergétique sur les chiffres et
il se trouve que les transformations la
matière qui produisent des biens et des
services
c'est ça qui font de la base du calcul
du pib' aussi
[Musique]